wie oder was genau hier soll max und wir
spielen heute zusammen mit meinem - du
wirst mir meinen spruch zerstört aber
ich habe mir auch gerade erst überlegt
gehabt spielen wir auf jeden fall
zusammen gibt und wie sollte es anders
sein und mein lieblingsteam modus und es
lag tatsächlich mehr ist auch dein
lieblingsspieler franz ja als tolle
sache ihr müsst wissen damals als der
get down heißt noch nicht so groß war
als noch nicht die mega op schwert den
get down wie das von nicht franz km 5
haben wir schon zusammen geht darum
gesuchte das waren schöne zeiten wie
justin sagen würde
es müssen ja shots gefeiert werden aber
sonst ich bin echt gut gestarten bisher
bei mir läuft richtig harte mal heiß ich
hab 720 dürfte auch so richtig heiß und
innig ja ich halte aber was was für eine
antwort 842 ich habe 683 nicht schlecht
was findest du also sehr gut - du titel
gefunden
ich wollte euch abgeholt haben alle
gesagt perfekte anfang
ich wollte euch noch erzählen
beziehungsweise zeigen wie letztens zu
ca die krasseste get down runde
überhaupt für mich angefangen hat da
habe ich zusammen mit justin aufgenommen
leider habe ich dann meine tonspur von
verloren und konnte das videolan aber es
war einfach vollkommen krank also ich
habe irgendwie am anfang von atlantis
prädikat ich kenne das für gibt's halt
manchmal so ist ein paar mehr blöcke am
anfang direkt on demand kann und ich hab
halt einfach jeden einzelnen job
bekommen wird nach vorne ans vorn war
und es waren insgesamt
ich glaube fünf stück aber von einer
richtung jetzt genau in eine richtung
fünf stück direkt hintereinander ist ich
hab auch noch ich habe auf den sound da
drin
das klingt und das ist richtig kraftvoll
ab gefeiert man sieht das neue der face
camp und dafür so ja und dann hatte ich
aus versehen weil ich an dem tag mal
ausnahmsweise vor politiker was ich
normalerweise nie mache das auch mit
grund für unsere games sieger uploads
ist sorry dafür habe ich dann alt warum
macht er denn so schnell einer feier
spiel der typ ist der finne stadt
genauso viele punkte wie ich ja ich habe
am meisten
was macht kein schwanz dass man die zu
klein franz ist okay ja ja ja ja
wenn franz eder in das gut findet dann
könnte ich das gut hast du bist ja glaub
ich schon ich hab einen runtergeholt ja
das war echt klasse kommission wirft als
kopf einer habe ich echt nicht okay egal
verstehe ich versteh ich kann ich bin
gerade voll den umweg gelaufen aber ich
glaube der wird sich hardcore und was
ist eigentlich auf atlantis immer so
erst am anfang so klocke da sind dann
weiß ich nicht genau die weißen runde
ohne und ich habe mich gewundert und
dachte dann entweder das abgeschafft
wurde
diese anfangs points aber dann hat meine
arbeitsstelle also gerade mit jackson
aufgenommen habe ich glaube ich am
letzten freitag
ich hab dann auch noch später gab es
wieder welche altersgruppe gab es keinen
einzigen dann kann ich auch nicht sagen
aber blieb also wirklich ich habe da so
gefeiert
übertreiben alle so aber ich hab voll
gut auf gut noch auf breite markt
besucht alimi
wir haben fast gleich viele kleine 50
menschen lasst uns team letzte tempels
nicht ich würde an seiner stelle op
schwert machen ungefähr bogen haben
er arbeite ich würze der server
gefährlich macht
naja wie du meinst du kannst keine
rüstung erkauft und den op drogenkriegs
nicht doch doch ich krieg das schon
zwölf in mein freund ich krieg das safe
in dann wirst du schon sehen ich
probiere es jetzt auch wie es
funktioniert nicht
okay da der kostet er nur wenig gesperrt
ich habe noch kein infiniti drauf ich
hole mir aber nur eisen
ach mist ich habe einen punkt verloren
und ich habe mein schwert das nicht
komplett op so misst ich habe ich hab
keinen scharfen schwert wissen dass
findet man aber das heißt jetzt in bogen
und mit ok kann ich aber schades drauf
kriegen sondern auch eine schutzwand
walter grath level rein wie ein
verrückter
das geht einfach nicht ich bin jetzt
gerade du bist am ende habe ich jetzt
überhaupt schadens auf mein schwert ich
weiß es nicht
der bogen ist auf jeden fall ziemlich
stark geht auch noch mit einer jazz was
los ich habe gerade ein schwert über
kirch selek hat jemand geglaubt ich kann
einen bogen nach anwenden boa und
abgestaubt also nicht ich aber sehe ich
leute six cup in katar
da mag
beim goldabbau programm was hätte fürs
leben noch weitere spieler als wir eher
links zu den dann machen wir schauen
nicht an gold ab ich hab euch scheiß
rüster irgendwer jedes spiel besser als
mein zwei zentner scharfen surfer thema
den berg hoch
hast du ein besseres schwert inzwischen
ich hab s 21 gefunden
ja ja ich glaube du bist mir da aber ich
hab jetzt keine teile mehr ich hatte
ich hab halt dafür enfinity und schärfe
45 camp kämpfen wir einfach gibt mir
immer gefallen ich habe den fall geben
oder ein paar
ich habe nur vier stücke nicht vorhaben
müssen vier stücke gegeben habe ich
hätte gar nicht da hat es noch einmal
mit kehrt nämlich viel stück hat noch
einen tipp lobbyisten oder gehört eine
aufgehoben weisen egal los geht's
gesten mal hast du an einer angel
natürlich lucky combo diaz und feuerball
dann musst du auch mit dem konzept
können ich hatte letztens auf meinen
schuhen wasserläufer ist alpha 3 ich
hatte also op gerüst und wasserläufe
diese insekten erteilt alle schutz 4
ja genau die teile auf land verstoße und
ich war halt im ich war im wasser
genauso schnell wieder auf land alter
mit wasserläufer 31
sie fällt dann wahrscheinlich bloß aus
wie heck so wenn man es ja mal haben
haben die auch an den chat geschrieben
naja ich hoffe mal leute euch hat das
video gefallen
es war mit grund dafür ist dass ich
einfach diesen krassen start zeigen
wollte bei atlantis und ich hoffe mal
dass du dich so weit gefallen und
software franz vorbei dann werdet euren
schwanz dabei x-factor gut oder